ciao ragazzi siete stanchi di tutte
quelle persone che vi dicono che siete
dei buoni a nulla che l'unica differenza
fra voi un celenterato sta nel fatto che
questo ai tentacoli e voi no ma
soprattutto siete stanchi di chi dice
che l'inglese potrete masticarlo
solamente con la museruola di un cane
beh a tutte queste persone e possiamo
rispondere solamente una cosa fango
learn sarà il fatto che sta per partire
per londra sarà il fatto che sono quindi
abbastanza carico per questa esperienza
visto che da un sacco di tempo non ci
vado e sono contentissimo perché passerà
questo tempo con luigi che vi fa ancora
più piacere ma fondamentalmente mi sono
ricordato di questa rubrica ora la
scorsa puntata abbiamo parlato di
consonanti di pronuncia è una cosa non
mi aspettavo che sarebbe andata così
bene vi è piaciuta tantisssimo e la
prima cosa che ho fatto è stata
chiedervi sia sui commenti di youtube
che su instagram di farmi sapere quali
sarebbero stati altri argomenti che
avreste voluto che io trattasse mamma
mia
l'italiano sempre il grande assente di
questa rubrica comunque avete creato
fuori richieste su ancora sulla
pronuncia mi avete chiesto di trattare i
verbi modali fabs avete chiesto di i
verbi in generale noi di castro insomma
un pochino di cose ma il commento che
forse ho trovato più di tutti è stato
quello di parlare di modi di dire e così
ho deciso prima di questo viaggio in
terra britannica di fare un elenco di
quelli che sono i miei tredici modi di
dire preferiti o due allievi che mi
faranno un pochino da specchio per
capire se quello che sto dicendo è
troppo difficile abbiamo jean marc il
mio studente preferito e enrico è il mio
odiato fratello allora partiamo quindi
subito con il primissimo modo di dire
allora il primo modo di dire che ho
scelto è appena i fogli sapete che cos'è
un penny
che cos'è una monetina esatto amy fosse
sarebbe un penny per i tuoi pensieri di
un modo carino per dire che ti passa per
la testa come per dire pagherei per
sapere quello che pensi
beh è che è un altro modo di vederla
assolutamente sì beni su youtube oppure
un penny per uno sciroppo per la tosse
che sarebbe ancora meglio che sapere
cosa passa da un orecchio all'altro
visto che probabilmente il vuoto
secondo modo di dire no me ne lei ne
legga una norma
no non hanno una gamma un armo enel ed
una frase potrebbe essere certamente sì
grazie per essermi sempre vicino a nome
nel ed è una cosa e viene utilizzata
quando si parla di costi quindi a
livello di è una gamba bravissimo quindi
un botto amaci tecnici di cosmi e nomine
lei e ho dovuto dare un rene bravissimo
è un gran modo ledere sembra comunque
certo io non sono d'accordo che non sono
molto pertinente no è esattamente la
trattiva bravissimo terzo modo di dire a
questo io lo amo lo amo alla follia
lo amo alla follia secondo me si sente
anche poco pachino si è bravissimo ma
che cos'è park boffo io pachina pronunci
viene utilizzato quando tu stai o
accusando la persona sbagliata a sei
stato tu hai fatto tu questa cosa tu sei
tra due oppure segue un pensiero
sbagliato io pachino pronunce cioè se
voto quando stai sbagliando sta
prendendo un granchio appunto il maestro
t t di t
ho preso un granchio si è negativo cioè
poi ti ci puoi fare gli spaghetti bono
però non è john mark iv modo di dire
questo uno dei primi che ho imparato tb
autobus che sarebbe male non è che lo
sta cogliendo il bersaglio
stai jeans cioè ci stai girando attorno
ma perchè non vai diretto al discorso
cioè smettila di girarci attorno che mi
vuoi dire
giorgio cespuglio il quinto modelli dire
abbastanza facile nel senso che è
abbastanza semplice da capire i conciari
che sat era tissimo l'aie non bisogna
mai fermarsi alle apparenze ora
sicuramente questo qui è un modo di dire
abbastanza conosciuto in generale nel
senso che immagino che se un italiano
dovesse incapparci non farebbe fatica a
tradurlo è uno di quei modelli dire che
in realtà sono più delle lezioni di vita
in generale per esempio se tu guardassi
enrico penseresti che è il solito
fannullone che non sa fare niente
ed è così perché rico non ha una
copertina una persona limpida e lo vedi
subito mette invece se tu bechi
gianmarco può sembrare una persona
distaccata tenebrose invece un piccolo
cucciolo di panda ok sesto modo di dire
questo qui è quello che sicuramente è
più simile all'italiano fra tutti quelli
che ho scelto sono proprio identici che
spicca parli col diavolo quello reagan
reagan nel esorcista parli del diavolo
eccolo là ok questo qui è abbastanza
semplice spicco del tempo ed eccolo qui
che arriva quando se non avete mai
sentito e l'italiano quando tu dici
parli del diavolo e ne aggiungiamo e
spuntano le corna intendiamo quelle
situazioni nelle quali parlando magari
dei qualcuno ti mando un messaggio
improvvisamente oppure compare
all'improvviso e tu dici mammamia parli
del diavolo ed eccolo là inglese
spigoloso conto dire di andare avanti
con il modo di dire numero 7 tra queste
adorabile schio sammons tanta tanta
tanta tanta fulmine tuono questa è una
miss conception lightning e fulmine
santa hepburn o la pancia di enrico
beh sì è una cosa di cui qualcuno non
proprio rubare vediamo se qua sotto
qualcuno lo sa fatemelo sapere
rubare il merito di qualcuno se tipo
gianmarco che è l'allievo preferito
perché esattamente
certo c'è la juve come fare come fare in
questi casi in inglese sinceramente no
hit è un tipo fox non è di mio interesse
però non è fra i miei modi dire
preferiti anche se a questo come
imbeccato da marco anche un tifo fatto
allora andiamo avanti a questo punto è
finito enrique e soprattutto in
fracassate voglio modo di dire numero 8
che forse è fra i miei preferiti in
assoluto è lo so ma questo l'ho scelto
apposta ma questo qui è proprio stupendo
e proprio la frase a effetto accessi
ovvero il m se no no no no sei molto
romantico vedete che un cucciolo di
panda soprattutto dovreste dirlo così
finalmente un pò medici della tua stessa
medicina non limonano lavora wow
certo dopo che preso uno sciroppo per la
tosse no
cos'è esattamente cioè i severi se vuol
dire un assaggio della tua medicina nel
senso una persona egoista ok prendiamo
così un esempio questo qui non presta
mai niente finché un giorno non gli
serve qualcosa
lo chiede a qualcuno e questo punto dice
no non te lo presto ma perché ti prego
ne ho bisogno di bello ti prego no non
trovò cioè se finalmente se è più come
per dire o ora sai cosa si prova e può
essere applicato in generale nei
confronti qualsiasi persona che di colpo
becca sulla sua becca su se stesso su se
stessa
un comportamento negativo che ha sempre
avuto con gli altri ci serviva il made
se andiamo avanti con il modo di dire
numero 89 always space essere space
space jam e che vuol dire una perdita di
speranza
no no no è una frase che dire come nei
confronti di una persona che per noi
occupa uno spazio in utile nel mondo che
lo spazio è quella persona occupa
potrebbe essere utilizzato per qualsiasi
cosa per agricoltura per aria e cose
così
ma è occupato da lui uno spreco di
spazio ho capito quindi se qualcuno ti
sta particolarmente simpatico a questo
punto mi verrebbe da dire per the space
cioè come come rubare come per te
sprecare spazio nel mondo con quella
persona lì ogni centimetro cubo del suo
del suo corpo potrebbe essere servito
per qualcosa di più utile che la sua
esistenza
però a questo punto modo di dire numero
10 10 gattinoni cyrus
[Musica]
forse rendere le proprie fosse fosse
porre all del buco on his e ai buchi
alti cioè le orecchie
fu strano bravo ho capito cos'è
vediamo per te prima era accedere ai
buchi altri no assolutamente no uno che
sei sul calo diventa autoritario però
anche arrogante e magari offensivo
il corso di cyrus che palle
sicuramente può essere sicuramente
perché magari chi stava a cavallo era il
cui il capitano ma era magari il
capitano che doveva rompere le palle
soldati non lo so stiamo inventando se
qualcuno lo sa ditecelo modo di dire
numero 11 allora questo è molto carino
shopping e shawn a ciò che dice sì cioè
una base pazzesca che cos'è una goccia
di luciano niente quanto pesa
niente quindi a volte un evento che tu
dici mamma mia è un casino
ieri mentre stavo lavorando certo punto
mi è cascato un bicchiere si ok ma
quanti ne portati in quella serata 2.500
ciò quindi novecento oppure al contrario
vorresti dire evitino tv set top
division frame tutto quel che faccio è
una goccia nell'oceano per lui cioè
sembra che niente riesca a smuovere
capito
sembra tutto quanto insignificante
chiaro questo quei poveri lamentosi modo
di dire numero 12 il penultimo modo di
dire è un modo di dire super inglese che
io amo tantissimo però per quanto
inglese che è un 12 snow ma capace il
peggio
solo chi lo zucchero no sono come
campione e come per dire non è una cosa
che non mi piace non il confort che ti
dà una bella tazza calda di tera bevi
così e ti piace cioè non mi fa impazzire
e può essere per un cibo per un'attività
per a pezzi molto molto gentile ma in
modo per dire vara non mi fa impazzire
ok la mia coppa soprattutto la mia tazza
e il calice in modo di dire numero 13
questo qui è inglese puro
questo è inglese puro non l'ho mai usato
non l'ho mai usato ma è anche forse
secondo me è uno dei più famosi box ho
anche un po bianco ancora c'è rancore
esatto quindi voi il rancore box one
sarebbe e bob tuo zio
no lo so che può sembrare lo so che può
sembrare che spari cazzate ma non è così
e vi dirò di più su questo ho fatto
anche una ricerca storica quindi so
esattamente perché si dice alessia
sì esiste anche un pop esisteva un
anchor pop e tifosi vuoi accendere un
computer
chi è né il pres box option che newton
liscia come l'olio liscio come l'olio
proprio il web ei cake vuoi fare una
torta ipsen flava ex sugar pop song con
il marchio perché perché nel 1887 il
primo ministro lo stesso rock pop pro
bells diminutivo di proprio stanno
cercando con una carica importante come
tipo segretario
dell'irlanda dell'irlanda che ha dato un
certo punto ha un certo alfred non mi
ricordo il cognome
ok tutti quanti che si vedono su alfred
cioè una carica così importante viene
data sto sconosciuto alfred bubo bubo
alfred era il nipote ha certo perché pop
franco cavedon accetto zio bob ti ha
dato la la cosa quindi quindi esatto se
quindi è liscia come l'olio
quindi se tu fai una cosa se sei nipote
di bob cioè sei tranquillo quindi
accendo il computer fa questo qui bob
tuo zio stai tranquillo ci ha capito che
vediamo che funziona questo è
carinissima ok questo è tutto per il
momento fatemi sapere se vi sono tornati
utili questi i modi di dire grazie mille
i miei allievi enrico pessimo come
sempre cioè marco anche due ottimo
ultimo rating no parte gli scherzi sono
stati molto bravi ma fatemi sapere voi
già vi conoscevate alcuni questi modi di
dire ci sono altri modi di dire che
magari vi piacciono un sacco in inglese
che non ho detto per esempio e che
magari già potrebbero interessare ad
alcune persone che magari scrollando fra
i commenti qui sotto vorranno scoprirne
qualcuno in più dei 13 che vi ho detto
semplicemente io
fatemi sapere che tipo di video vorreste
vedere all'interno di questo canale ma
soprattutto fatemi sapere se potrebbe
piacervi anche se ancora stiamo cercando
un pochino un modo per farlo in maniera
che funzioni che non sia un ginepraio e
un macello totale delle rette twitch in
inglese nelle quali poter parlare fare
insegna vorremmo aprirci a trichet e
secondo me è un modo al di là di quello
del gaming della chiacchiericcio renale
potrebbe anche essere quello di diciamo
traghettare questa rubrica lì non ho
ancora ben chiaro come farlo ma fatemi
sapere se una cosa a live vi potrebbe
piacere ha detto ciò come sempre vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo canale
fatevi veramente saper qua sotto non lo
so qual è il vostro modo di dire
preferito in italiano o in inglese che
sia e magari se ne vedete qualcuno
provate a tradurli
specialmente se ne beccate alcuni
italiano magari sei riuscito a trovare
una controparte in inglese sarebbe utile
magari per la persona che l'ha detto e
che quindi scopre un modo per per dirlo
in un'altra lingua
detto ciò che altro dire chi è che siamo
arrivati alla fine metteteci un bel
pollice in su anche se in questo caso
sono due ma abbondare non c'è mai
dispiaciuto io vi do un abbraccio grande
ci vediamo questa domenica con la nuova
puntata di cucina buttata ciao